i am sitting here with the legends
themselves metallic i've been waiting
for this date for months
this is insane you've been talking about
it for months you know we were playing a
gun some roses song while you guys were
getting set up
did i remember you guys had a whole
thing with them right james right you
hated those [ __ ] guys
you went on tour with them and it was
just a nightmare wasn't it
do i have that right you do have it
right yeah what was the rub there
because those guys are infamously late
and uh was that the the rub or were they
just primitive they were always late
that's why i hated them was that they
think they pretty much stood for
everything we didn't like the glam the
la the everything everything we kind of
escaped in the early days you know yeah
because everything i know about you guys
and you know i think people think rock
stars are going to be late they don't
care about their fans you guys even at
the apollo saturday night you're there
you start on time you don't no [ __ ]
with everyone waiting for you like prima
donnas i appreciate that so much
yeah
it's important to me
you guys look like you were having fun
what i saw saturday night is a
tremendous amount of energy have you
ever weighed yourselves in terms of how
much weight you lose during a show i'm
being serious
would you lose five
fighters like fighters i mean
i know my friend said my friend wanted
to put a pedometer on me because you
know the the death magnetic stage and uh
i mean it took up the whole hockey arena
he wanted to see how how far we ran
during the show it is an amazing amount
of energy and the thing i kept thinking
when i was watching you saturday night
and even when i saw the concert film
which by the way is a beautiful film
i've never seen a band shot that well
and the sound to be that intense
and we'll talk about that in a minute
but when i'm watching you guys you
genuinely appear to be having fun
and i was wondering like i was actually
nervous for you i said that's a small
haul it's 1500 people are you going to
give a [ __ ] and you're just going to go
through the motions and i i got the
feeling that you guys were moved by
being in the apollo theater is that true
so much history there obviously and when
people are that close it really makes
you uh step up i mean
you couldn't see it from where you were
but there's three three levels
so everybody on the floor close
everybody on the second tier are really
closing people so you can basically see
everybody in the hole in the whole
venue and everybody just feels like
they're sitting right on top of you so
you're playing to every single person
and then it's really cool and after all
these years it still feels new to you
when you're playing something that small
well especially when you're playing a
place like that you know it's got such
musical history and we're pretty much
honored to be in a place like that uh
but the small gig you know no matter
what the gig is
we get nervous and we're excited about
it you do get nervous totally well
because you mentioned that during the
show when you say you were nervous some
songs are harder to play than others
right right and by that you mean i i
notice
that that when you and kirk are playing
together sometimes i'm reminded of the
allman brothers because when dickey
betts and dwayne allman used to be able
to jam together they were one of the few
guys that could play dual leads and
harmonize with their leads
and you guys appear to be doing that
same trick but i think that's tough to
do i think that's the hardest thing to
do how many bands do that a big
inspiration on james and i was that band
thin lizzy they played a lot of guitar
harmonies right and you know once you
once you figure out what your each guy
is going to be playing you stick to that
it's it's it's pretty easy does the
rehearsal time for a tour get insane
because you know i think people think
you wing it when you're up there and
each time it's a little different
there's no wing in it right i mean you
guys have to be that precise i'll tell
you something lately i feel like we've
kind of been winging it you know we've
been on this incredible
uh schedule whether it's a press
schedule or just even with our families
you know because we really balance
everything out yeah and um
and the scary thing is is we've been
pulling it off i mean we flew into
denmark for roskilde festival and we
actually had a great show and then the
other night we were in uh rio de janeiro
for rock and rio and we pulled that off
and we were like really in the twilight
zone we our time body clock was off
because it seems like you've got a lot
to memorize in a sense
i think it's it's a lot of trust it's a
lot of trust that when you get up there
if you have the confidence that you know
you're you're pretty good at what you
got going on and you've knocked the rust
off at least on your own when you get up
there you have to trust that whatever
happens in the moment you're going to be
able to be okay with it like i'm sure
you on your show whatever's thrown at
you
you you feel confident about and you can
you can trust that the right thing is
going to happen next how old were you
when you started playing guitar
i think 14 14.
up until then no music lessons nothing
like that yeah i had uh uh i had to take
piano lessons and you hated it i hated
it and the guitar was your salvation
because you knew you wanted to be a
musician in some weird way and then you
get a hold of a guitar and you start
playing
and did someone teach you to play the
guitar or you just learned that on your
own i did learn it on my own that's
[ __ ] crazy to me
how old are you when you write your
first song uh i think it was 15 15. yeah
and like the band hated it so i fired
him
and it took you a long time to figure
out how to sing in the sense that um
still figuring it out i was listening to
an early
this is an early record recording and
you were you you were trying to find
your voice i feel um and you almost
sounded like more like robert plant
than the guy you sound like today am i
correct i'm going to play a little of
this tell tell me what comes to mind
all three of them but when you're an
artist and you start thinking about
doing a band and all that stuff don't
you get sort of confused
uh in terms of like how do i find like
why when i first got into radio
i used to talk up here i was nervous i
was tight my voice wouldn't drop and i
talked really fast and nasally do you
know what i'm saying totally when do you
find your style that we all know today
well you do it a lot right you tour a
lot and you you build up confidence you
build up confidence within
your little family around you
and they guide you too you know you can
you ask questions like what does that
sound like or you know you listen to
yourself back and you go wow i'd rather
not sound like that i noticed i noticed
a big um
because even in the early days when we
were playing clubs and stuff around la
and san francisco james was so shy that
he didn't even used to talk to the
audience dave mustain our guitar player
used to do all the talking right i
noticed the biggest transformation was
the first time we went to europe in 1984
we got out in front of the european
audiences and there were thousands of
them just welcoming us you know and
they've been waiting for us for a couple
years and i noticed a big change in
james he all of a sudden started finding
himself and communicating with the
audience and getting a lot more
confident yeah and that's a tough thing
to develop it just happens with
thousands of hours of practice you know
i was watching led zeppelin getting this
kennedy center honors
and i was thinking about you guys uh you
guys rock harder even in zeppelin and
i've been to zeppelin shows back in like
the the early 70s
and i was thinking would you guys want
an honor like the kennedy center honors
or would you laugh at something like
that do you laugh when you see led
zeppelin getting honored in a very
traditional way
i'm curious i don't laugh you know i i
think it's great that they they're still
after all these years are still being
acknowledged and getting awards like
that and i just hope that that you know
when we're old old and fat and older
older and fatter yeah but if metallica
was asked to go to the chelsea if
metallica was asked to go to the kennedy
center honors and be honored you would
do something traditional like that or
would you just say hey [ __ ] that that's
just too
that that's not us
we depends on where it's coming from you
know we don't have an across-the-board
policy about that type of stuff we look
at each one of them go that's cool
that's not so cool i think that um
we've always been open to receiving that
type of stuff because we've always felt
that the accolades that come our way you
know we've done everything our way on
our terms you know what i mean yeah we
did it all our own [ __ ] way we we we
did it the metallica way we never sold
out we never
did anything for other than just what we
felt was pure and honest and so kennedy
centered sure
to washington
yeah right i find the greatest bands are
the ones that don't sell out in other
words you could have changed your sound
to a more commercial sound you know you
could have been pressured into that by a
record company i was watching you know
you guys were going through like sort of
the history of metallica on stage
saturday night and even in the movie you
do this and i and i'm listening to these
songs and i'm like at any point someone
could have said to you look this isn't
commercial and you say yeah [ __ ] it
let's just you know we'll write we'll
write a real commercial album and we'll
sell our sound out and you never did it
and that's why i think the audiences
still respond to you guys i agree
completely they see the honesty in what
you do and at
you know it's all relative someone
we've heard that we've sold out
a million forever right but it's all
relative to what your world is and how
small your world is so we've we've we've
stayed honest to ourselves and that's
all we can also all we can do when did
the sellout [ __ ] start when the
black album came out
way before that ride the lights
on the second album we had a song called
fade to black that we still play almost
at every show and um
james thought it would be a great idea
to have acoustic guitars on the album
right so when the metal community heard
a metallica song with acoustic guitars
they all lost their [ __ ] lunches
big time this is the song you're talking
about there you go the big sell out and
to me this is 29 years ago it is one of
the most beautiful songs out there
i mean wow what a song
[Music]
well fade to black
[Music]
lars said the writing of this song that
that james you were obsessed with death
that this was your death obsession is
that true
uh still am somewhat i think there's a
fear of death that we all kind of
struggle with and battle with i think at
that point i remember writing fade to
black uh uh
everything was metal joe's metal on
metal joe's couch
metal joe you don't know metal joe no
metal joe
i don't know man joe infamous metal joe
he took us in when our manager uh
basically kicked us out of his house
and
jersey yeah
old bridge new jersey 1983 old bridge we
lived out on his farm and we just
partied and played and wrote songs and
uh
i think at that point we were supposed
to go
we were supposed to go to europe for the
first time
twisted sister yeah and our gear had
gotten stolen we got the phone call that
not only
was our well our our our
then tour manager
had a u-haul filled with our gear
someone stole the whole u-haul
it doesn't get more depressing than that
when you're a band and your gear is
stolen you don't have the money to
replace you can't even play right we
were lucky that we we had our guitars
with us so
it was so cold in boston that's where
they got so so now you can joke about it
but at that point you were so depressed
and all your gear was stolen and then
you start thinking about jesus what the
hell is life all about and we're gonna
die anyway
more like our career's over we're
screwed we're you know and then you come
up with this yeah
it gives me chills
it's fantastic
[Music]
do you guys think you're given the
acknowledgement as musicians that you
deserve i was watching lars first of all
and i've heard guys say oh lords isn't
the greatest drum
i never saw a guy drum like this [ __ ]
guy on stage saturday night i've never
seen anybody do it i don't know how the
hell you do it don't you think you don't
get enough credit
and i'm not just sucking your balls
because you're here i know you're not
man i'm not
you know we have our own thing and and
we have our own you know we're not none
of us are sort of virtuosos you know we
we don't uh
you know in the metal community there's
a lot of who's the fastest guy and who's
the most gifted and who can go but a
little bit faster than the other guy
that's never been our thing we were
always more about songs the main thing
the melody and the the song and the feel
the purity and the the sort of the band
vibe and all that stuff about who's the
fastest drummer and kurt better than the
guy caught up in that [ __ ] we never
got caught up everybody else got caught
up in that and so
along the way
we were just more comfortable just being
ourselves and and so there was a little
bit i think from the heavy metal
community a little bit of disdain that
we weren't sort of serious enough but we
weren't you know practicing enough but
we weren't all this type of stuff and
that's people have been throwing at us
for almost 30 30 years and it doesn't
matter robert i was watching you play
the bass and are you channeling a little
jack bruce there when you play chords on
your bass because he was like the first
guy to do that wasn't he
oh yeah definitely
were you a fan of cream yeah yeah i mean
i grew up listening to everything from
motown that was the thing that was so
impressive um the spirit of the apollo
because all everything from buddy holly
to james brown to jimi hendrix and you
know what's funny the temptations i mean
and i grew up on that stuff
and that's kind of the same stuff that
um jack bruce and even like geezer
butler you know they all came up with
that i mean led zeppelin
wouldn't be led zeppelin if it wasn't
for the apollo because all those bass
lines that john paul jones was playing
were inspired by james jamerson
and uh well what i thought was funny i
was reading the reviews of the show they
were fabulous but they were saying how
you guys musically have no roots to the
apollo people and that's [ __ ]
anybody in rock and roll has roots
because you were joking on stage james
like i can't even believe they let us in
here because you know but the fact is
you guys do draw on some of the great uh
r b artists right i mean it's it's just
because it's metal doesn't mean it's not
yeah it's all i mean it's all linked i
mean a lot of a lot of hard rock and
metal obviously comes from the blues you
know deep purple led zeppelin that go
you cream like you were just talking
about that all goes back to the blues
and obviously the blues is linked to
everything that was going on up at the
apollo so
it's all connected like a spiderweb way
back there you know one of the great
moments in the show is uh the marianne
uh faithful uh thing you know
[Music]
to me this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
when i was in the audience everybody
joins in and sings that part
that is an incredible moment doesn't
that give you the chills when everyone
knows your song it's beautiful it's a
beautiful thing searching i mean
at least my life been searching for
connection and belonging everywhere in
my
all my life and when someone's singing
along to your lyrics there's nothing
more connecting yeah oh it's so
beautiful how did you think of marianne
faithful because first of all who even
knew her voice got that deep you know
what i mean uh how did you try to hook
up with her on that song i think she
might have had a cigarette or two yeah i
think so in between i don't know
yeah we got hooked up with her i mean
the whole song idea is based around
sunset boulevard and the the the star
that is is still in in the bubble of
of greatness even though the time has
passed and her voice had had a lot of
weather-ness or whatever the word it was
weathered yeah
there's a beauty to it i mean still like
an absolute beauty you know and bob rock
our producer uh suggested her right
right
and uh james and i flew over to uh to
dublin with the master tapes under our
arms and walked into a recording studio
met marianne faithful and she uh had a
glass of wine and did it in about what
two takes
and it was so cool we were just sitting
there going holy [ __ ]
there was this legend singing our song
and she just nailed it right that was
the thing that blew my mind i don't
think you showed her the melody like
one go around and then she just needed
oh it's so classic
[Music]
oh and then that went on for 10 minutes
and i was like hey this is great let's
just keep doing this all night we don't
have to keep going howard i think you're
showing off because you sing it so well
you guys didn't realize i'm missing the
one thing he sings well yeah you know uh
next time man next time we're in town
come leave the choir talk to me the song
we're gonna do first by the way we're
here to celebrate a lot of things that
metallic is in the studio also there's a
new 3d film i've seen the film and uh
it's very hard to describe it's called
through the never while i i don't want
to say it's entirely a concert film
because there's some kid in there
getting the [ __ ] beaten out of them and
all kinds of crap going on but i get it
i was in the audience we were all
punching each other during the metallica
show it got really weird on saturday
night like guys were like richard uh is
your biggest fan you know him he uh he
was wearing a diaper because he didn't
want to miss anything so he pisses into
the diaper and he's drinking richard did
you know that yeah where is he here yeah
he's here yeah yeah i promised him he
could watch you guys play one but
um to me one is anti-war of course right
i mean what what are we talking about
here you guys have a lot of military
themes in your music there's a lot of
stuff about war
and yet i feel it's the band is very
sort of
anti-war am i correct
you
you might be correct in
a few members
[Laughter]
no i think are you split uh uh uh
politically
uh i don't i don't know we don't
we don't really discuss that too much
because politics and religion separate
people i think and we're about bringing
people together really well you you guys
uh i get from your music that you feel
religion
is sort of
a joke
well yeah first it's all up to the
person man i'm all about freedom
pretty much and if you know war is a
part of man as simple as that we're just
writing about it
good or bad you're just writing about it
it's not good or bad it's just a thing
yeah to me the song one is where i first
started to get to know you guys because
of the video and all that kind of stuff
and
the thought of a guy
locked
in his body
i mean the guy has no senses
where did this song first of all how do
you start writing a song about all this
my brother uh older brother dave who was
he also played in a band uh played drums
he uh i don't know he told me a story
about i guess some some he was
uh
whatever reading a book and which was
johnny got his gun telling me about this
guy who yeah he was like a prisoner in
his own body and i related to that
because i felt that
not that i couldn't speak or or hear or
use my limbs but for some reason i
connected with that like being stuck in
your own skin and how uncomfortable that
can feel and that would be like the
ultimate hell
where you can't communicate to anybody
so the song is about a guy who's trapped
inside his own body he has no arms he
has no legs he can't taste he can't see
he can't smell or talk and in a way you
felt like that right because if you you
had a miserable childhood when i read
about your childhood i think
i don't even know how you survived that
in a sense
well uh and and the the crazy thing is
you know i i grew up thinking that it
was just normal and i think i'm not i
thought your childhood was normal yeah
because how would you know otherwise
exactly your father left
when uh you were what 16 13 yeah
he leaves and you never hear from the
guy again right i mean pretty much he
didn't support the family he did not
right and your mom
she died shortly thereafter of cancer
right yeah a few years later so you were
basically orphaned
yeah did it drive you insane that your
father even after your mother died
didn't get in touch with you
he did try to get in touch with me i i
really wanted nothing to do with it i
mean i i it was a it was uh
you know um
there's a movie that that i've been
interviewed for which is called absent
about fathers and uh the the absence of
a male role model in a lot of children's
lives and how in how that impacts uh
their upbringing
and uh i've come to a lot of closure
with all that stuff you know my dad did
his best i understand that uh did he
wasn't enough did he do his i guess
that's what anyone can do exactly right
yeah he had no father either so if you
trace it back
there's you can make sense of it all so
you and you're a pretty good dad right
i'm doing my best so i'm saying you had
no role model you probably had to go
learn all this stuff about how to be a
dad fear of not being a good dad is it's
a real fear that guys just don't want to
talk about and it's okay to put it out
there you know because that's what i'm
doing you know you don't and so how do
you get lessons on how to be a dad if
you don't have one that even showed you
how to be one right well you ask your
friends and asking is sometimes tough
that is because it shows uh transparency
and realness and you want to
look like you're the macho dude and know
what you're doing yeah probably
admitting that you don't know what
you're doing is probably the best thing
in the world and it's the best thing for
the kids to hear actually
your life got even wackier because your
mom was a um
what do you call a christian scientist
or something she didn't believe in any
medications right and that's probably i
thought where most of your anger came
from absolutely that your mom was saying
hey
um
i'm dying to cancer i don't want any
medicine and people would say no
medicine and that's probably you in your
mind you thought well if you take some
medicine on maybe you'd still be around
yeah it drives you crazy right uh and
but she wouldn't even admit that she had
cancer i mean that was the whole the
whole the whole religion itself uh
didn't make much sense to me that if
even if you even if me and my sister
mentioned
mom you look sick then that is admitting
it and that is going to let the
the thing in that actually kills her so
we can't be a part of you know i don't
want to kill my mom it's like almost
watching her die yeah it's magical
thinking it's crazy in a day and age
when they had drugs and things that
could help keep people alive she
wouldn't go to a hospital or anything
like that right right so that's why when
we hear this song one
we're not just talking about a guy who's
had his limbs cut off and had his senses
all you know and he's locked inside his
head it's very much you who had you know
you were cut off from the rest of the
world in a sense and very alone you're
the guy with his limbs cut off wow
all right now play that song and don't
cry
have you ever cried how much do i owe
you for this therapy session do you did
you cry when you wrote this song because
sometimes when i hear it i'm almost on
the verge of tears i really am
that's great that's great
i did not now i might thanks all right
this is the song
done live in our little studio right now
and uh richard if you want since you had
a mega mustache you could sit on the
couch and don't freak these guys out
where is he uh he he freaks us out how
is he not going to break that well lars
you're the reason richard started
drumming by the way did you have smegma
hey richard yeah how's that do you
forgot to smell the shrimp on your dude
or what i washed my face with scalding
hot water yeah to get rid of this magma
i wish you guys could have seen him at
your concert first of all he can't move
his neck now because he's [ __ ] he's
he there was more like
the concert was more about him than you
guys
i was getting into it and by the way i
cried during one every time you do cry
yeah i'm gonna try not to now because i
don't want to look like a [ __ ] in front
of these guys but i can almost cry right
now just thinking that i'm in the room
with them
well tell tell lars about why you
started drumming
because of lars i mean when i heard kill
them all and you taught me how to play
double bass from the one video the shot
of you playing heels up behind i saw
that i'm like oh that's how you do it
and so i owe everything to you you wanna
come sit over here you know he actually
wants to play during
this he owes everything to lars lars he
lived in a what was it a a storage
locker he lived in a storage uniform
what band were you wearing for 12 years
charred walls of the damned we played
orion fest last year that's right yeah
all right the guy enough about that
the guy that the guy that gave us our
first record deal brian slagle way back
in in 83 is also the label that you guys
are on he was there saturday night
there's a connection yeah and the big
difference is he sold one album and you
sold millions
this is called one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i can't remember anything
can't tell if this is
[Music]
i cannot see
that is not much left of me
nothing is real but paid now
my breath is
[Music]
look to the time when i live
[Music]
my breath is i wish
god
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now the world is
oh please god help me
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughing
no no now
[Music]
[Music]
so
true
so
uh
oh
richard's diaper is full
you like that you prick
that was the greatest thing ever that is
beautiful tell me how you write a song
like that because i want to write a song
like that what happens now now
what is the the lars do you
what happens there james how do you
write that song
uh what is that like what's the process
do you have that you got yourself in the
garage for a while and uh who comes up
with the music
i think uh boy i don't remember that
part uh that song i think we all put
riffs together as we go through life we
have riffs and we have a rift tape and
we pick out the best rift and
uh we slap them together and how do you
come up with the lead vocal on that
because it's i mean when i hear that i
wouldn't even know where to jump in and
start singing you know what i'm saying i
mean uh who right who writes most of the
lyrics me it's a it's a 90 personality
thing yeah okay when you write those
lyrics
do you write them in a room by yourself
or do you sit there and wait for the
riffs yeah great question sometimes uh
there's poetry that's written sometimes
uh just certain lines come up uh that
are strong enough to start an idea right
uh and other times it's here's the music
i know the melody fill in the blanks
so it's like a puzzle so did you have
when you were a kid did you have poetry
books did you read poetry not at all not
at all you don't strike me as the poetry
you used to strike music i was like
beating people up and [ __ ] and fighting
and stuff you know what i mean you don't
strike me as the poetry type i was not
beating people up but were you shocked
the other way you you were busy getting
beaten up yeah mentally but that was
your thing
your dad's physically beating james was
really really shy yeah there was there
was you know that was a whole nother
generation of of uh discipline but for
me getting into a room and kind of
closing off is where it happens a lot of
times when i think i want i'm you know
going somewhere with a lyric it'll take
you somewhere else and it's that's the
beauty of it you don't really know where
it's going do you think that your
teachers would be surprised that you
became a lyricist someone who could
write lyrics there's no doubt about that
yeah because probably no one had you
pegged for that no no were you even
shocked that all this came out of you
all this poetry yeah i learned a lot
from music from other musicians from
other uh uh you know people that were
writing lyrics you know
there's there were singers that i
admired there were people that i that i
liked their lyrics maybe not liked their
music uh um but i have since you know
continued to discover uh different
lyricists that i enjoy so when you wrote
nothing else matters
which is considered uh a softer song a
ballad really right yeah you were
embarrassed to bring that to the band
right because not only are you a shy
person but also it was a love song to a
girlfriend at the time right
and so when you so would you have buried
that song rather than bring it to them
and how did it end up in the band's
hands i think lars heard it and said hey
that's really good and i said no it's
not how did lars hear that song if you
were ashamed of it
how did you hear it
you played it for me
that's how he heard it
so you weren't that ashamed and did lars
did he come to you did james come to you
and go hey man i'm going to play
something for you
you know i mean it's always been there's
always been a very open door policy i
mean we all trade usually what would
happen back in the early days is that
when we would after a tour go on break
like james would give me all his uh
ideas kurt would give me all his ideas
we'd all sort of trade ideas and then
we'd go away and then we'd start writing
a few months later everybody would kind
of have an idea of what everybody else
was bringing to the table what a weird
process you're almost like the guy
everyone sort of dumps all their ideas
into and you've got to organize the
ideas is that it
he's the only organized guy in this band
he's best suited for that job he's our
manager but lars i mean when you think
about lars and james right you think
about two guys from opposite ends of the
world do you think about lars was a from
a wealthy family tennis playing family
the whole thing
and then you see james in a way go you
know just kind of like in this shitty
situation with his parents the idea that
you two guys got together is insane
right that the whole band found each
other is insane well i think we found
something each other that we're missing
i mean you know i found
you know i grew up an only child and
found you know my best friend found a
brother and found somebody who could
relate to everything that i was going
through and james at that time like we
said was painfully shine kind of in his
own world everything about being in a
band and i think hard rock at that time
was about you belonging to something
bigger than yourself what keeps you guys
together though do you think do you do
do you think that it's that uh even
through like you guys had some shitty
times together you had some good times
together are you real brothers do you
think the band will always be together
is there any way this band could ever
break up
i think that's why we're still together
we've gone through fire together
and uh do you still see each other
socially or no it doesn't go that way
i don't know uh
when's the last time you guys are all
hunting socially
you mean going out and hanging out like
when you're not families together right
you know yeah i don't think that happens
too often i think we we
we know we respect each other and
they're in our and our privacy and our
boundaries with our families we get
together for parties at hq you know the
the halloween party at hq is kind of the
most awesome time with all the kids
together but i think we've stayed
together because of that honesty and the
fact that you know like in the some kind
of monster movie we walk through fire
and that's true we know that we can
conquer anything anything that comes at
us we've we've kind of been through it
you know it's amazing and we care for it
and there is that fifth member like lars
was talking about earlier yeah we're not
you know i'm not in the best singer pole
i'm not you know we're not individually
amazing musicians but together
the fifth member is a force that you
need to reckon with so the song nothing
else matters
in a weird way
let me tell you something
what if i said to you
that this song could possibly
be james's song to lars
what do you think of that very true
it's a love song to your brother lars
you probably didn't know that when you
were writing it you think you were
writing it for a while you're crying i'm
sure
you have to
try to face you you have to turn around
in facebook
but this is a beautiful love song that
really came to really came to be because
a large you gave james the confidence to
release this song i said i just you know
when i heard it
it was in a kind of a rough state uh the
all the parts on it now weren't there
but when i heard the verses i'd never
heard james sing like that and it just
moved me and i knew that this was
something that we had to share with the
rest of the world he felt
i think too vulnerable at that time to
sort of let that out there but i knew
that um this was something that had to
be shared with everybody the woman you
wrote this song for did she know you
wrote it for her does she have any idea
or you never told her i think so maybe
it's gone way beyond that
you know people come up to us and say we
used it at our wedding we this and that
i mean the the hells angels had it in a
little movie that they put together so
it is about brotherhood as well and it
and it's vague enough to relate to
everything and and and needing and
needing another human you know all right
here we go don't get me wrong
this is for lars
[Music]
so
[Music]
so close no matter how far
[Music]
who we are
and nothing else
[Music]
never open myself this way
life
[Applause]
words is don't just say
no nothing else matters
[Music]
trust i see
and i find it new
[Music]
nothing else
[Music]
oh
[Music]
could be much more from the
heart forever trust who we are
no nothing else
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
i never opened myself this way
life is
[Music]
[Music]
no nothing else
[Music]
never cared
[Applause]
[Music]
cause i know
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
beautiful
beautiful
how do you decide which guy takes the
lead between you and kirk how do you
like like you guys trade off right
what do you mean he does it
how he's better
what do you mean he's better you think
he's a better guitar player than you
yeah no
you know actually what happens is
whoever
has a a a better feel for for uh
the part usually
dictates who's gonna play the solo but a
lot of times james just like uh defers
to me because he likes rocking out and
playing rhythm guitar on stage you're
not comfortable playing lead and not
having to worry about not having to
think too much about it because he
leaves it to me i don't kirkland lead i
like writing leads i like melody i love
playing the melodies i love working out
the harmonies and things yes but
actually playing them
you don't enjoy it
you'd rather hand that off to kirk i
would kirk why do you honor white
zombies he's the ripper on your uh
guitar you have a sticker for white
zombie the band no actually it's the
movie white zombie from 1932. oh so
you're not honoring a rob zombies down
nothing to do with rob zombie at all
it's just a movie that i really like i'm
a big horror movie fan i also have a
mummy guitar that has the mummy on it
speaking guitars james you play a black
guitar i mean i'm into the aesthetic
also of a band does it matter to you
what a guitar looks like does that does
that factor into it
well for me
guitar has to look good sound good and
play good
right
but uh james the guitar you were playing
has like an iron cross on it it's a
black guitar and i saw that go that's
the coolest [ __ ] guitar i ever saw
does that matter to you what it looks
like sure it does right yeah i i i like
having a guitar that looks pretty cool
yeah what was that guitar the black one
with the cross on the iron cross yeah
that's the iron cross it's called the
iron cross guitar
and do you have a favorite guitar
uh i would say this one the snake bite
the snake bites snake bite it kind of
looks like a retro kind of look right
the guitar second explorer shape but
with uh it's thinner it's lighter it's
uh it's got some barbs on it like the
metallica logo and uh the explorer shape
just hangs on me well it's it's it's
just a feel thing
you can sit down and play
you know with the thing so it is about
feel
and lars you uh knew that song was going
to be a hit you had an argument with the
wrestlers it wasn't it wasn't so much
about hit it was just more about a side
of metallica that i was really proud of
and i thought that everybody should see
were you scared that the fans would
revolt when they heard such a beautiful
ballad no i think it's good to challenge
the fans once in a while actually it
doesn't matter to you talk to me about
this movie why put out a movie now and
who convinced you to do this i like the
movie because i feel i've never seen a
musical performance recorded that
beautifully
what is it a special technique that they
record this thing with i'm talking about
the sound and the look well we asked our
director you know most concert films are
shot from the outside yeah looking at
the band we wanted the guy to shoot it
from the inside so you really feel like
you're up on stage with metallica which
i think is what you're talking about
that you're really part of what's going
on in the trenches you're being spit on
you're being sweated on you're really
right there with the band and so his
marching orders were get up on stage
bring your cameras
up there and shoot out so you really you
know you sort of there's shots behind
james behind rob right the idea is that
i feel like i'm in the band exactly i'm
playing with you guys exactly yeah i got
that from the film i liked it i liked it
a lot those were the marching orders and
greg fiddleman who's been doing all our
sound stuff for the better part of the
last five years did all the the the
audio and just stepped it up
we had the premiere in san francisco
what a week or two ago and on the big
imac screen out there and it sounded
just [ __ ] next level now how nervous
are you guys about a movie coming out
that's a metallica movie i'm talking
about from a commercial sense i mean you
don't i don't care how successful you
are and how much money you've made you
always want a project to be commercially
successful yes yeah it's a risk to do a
movie
there's no doubt about that who decide
who did anyone in the band say let's not
do this why should we put ourselves
through that kind of pressure yeah that
was a time when we were really scared
about it i know at least lars and i
had had we freaked out it's like you're
gonna have a 3d movie of us up there in
this theater it's like who wants to see
that
you know uh we've seen you too we've
seen uh the stones we've seen okay it's
there for a minute i watched it done
that's it how is this thing gonna have
any legs whatsoever you know it's
flattering to the ego though isn't it i
mean to see yourself in imax and all of
that but at the same point it's like who
the [ __ ] needs this pressure now there's
a movie studio that's how much money
does it cost to make a movie like that i
imagine it's very expensive yeah sure it
is a couple of million bucks right movie
world is a whole nother level
so for us getting the narrative in there
was very important
and and i know all of us you know we've
seen ourselves thousands of times on
video and whatnot we wanted to see the
narrative we wanted more narrative more
story more uh uh you know more of dana
dahan yeah i like that you broke up the
movie with uh a guy in a story and and
something going on remind me of the old
music videos where you see a little
action going on to try to put a
different spin on it i mean it was uh
you know
all these other concert movies and these
documentaries and we don't need to
mention names but they become more like
infomercials it's like here we are
getting in and out of a plane and here
we are getting in our limo and right
here we are folding you know lunch meat
on a sandwich and all this stuff and
mention the names of bands who have done
that did you find sellouts
and we just felt that metallica we don't
need to do that so what else can you do
we'll put a story in there
and so you know we found you know the
the greatest you know actor of his
generation in hollywood you know dan
dahan how do you find that kid
he just
i mean there was a dude a couple three
years ago there was a movie called
chronicle never mind chronicle remember
that kid on um in treatment yeah did you
watch that show hbo show yeah the kid
was good does he come and meet metallica
and you guys have to approve him as the
guy gets his ass kicked all over the
place
he actually met with our director first
and the two of them hit it off you know
it was a very difficult script to read
because
you've written movie scripts and there's
basic there's no dialogue in the film so
he was handed a 15-page script with no
dialogue and he sat there trying to make
heads and tales of it and he finally met
our director yes and there's tons of
violence which i think goes it's weird
with your band it goes hand in hand i
got to see a guy get his [ __ ] ass
kicked i got to see car crashes i got to
see blood and you did provide all of
that fire why is there why is that we
just need it right
you know i was thinking about uh
blitzkrieg if i may mention this for a
second i'm in the gym the other day and
i've told people this and i'm ashamed of
it when i bench press i bench 90 pounds
now but that's 10 times
suddenly this song comes on
[Music]
and i'm bit that's right i'm benching
about a hundred
i added 10 pounds to the stack
it gets you [ __ ] charged up look at
that
[ __ ] you i'll kick your ass
right now who wants to fight
[Music]
don't you think your songs
live something howard don't you think
your songs inspire violence in a weird
way they have to right you have to beat
the [ __ ] out of somebody when you're
listening to
our songs our songs have a lot of
adrenaline well they have a lot of
aggression and they they they cause a
lot of adrenaline to flow yeah i was
punched
when fighter pilots very well sometimes
they're getting ready that's what
they're blasting
in their ears so if they can get ready
to go do what they have to do sports
figures yeah everyone says yeah what was
the uh the uh the classic thing the
military was using metallica music to
torture prisoners with right and you
guys the iranians
or something i don't know who who were
they torturing them who were we fighting
with the afghanis
who are we killing at that moment yeah
so so what i'm saying is you guys how do
you put a stop to that when when the
military starts using your your music to
torture people how do you put a stop
it really didn't do anything i mean it
seems like it's you know once your music
is out there
yeah you don't have control it's not
yours anymore so much
you know obviously with the internet you
know it's uh does it bother you to hear
that it's being used for torture
you're watching our fans for years i
have i had a great fantasy
our friends and family with it i had a
great fantasy when i heard that story
and this the fantasy i had was so you
guys your music is playing and they're
torturing some guy and this guy hears it
and he gets turned on to metal music and
it starts a whole new genre of metal in
some of these muslim countries
[Music]
we played a couple times over in um in
abu dhabi and in that area there i mean
there are a lot of kids over there that
are really really really
passionate about this kind of music they
come in we played in abu dhabi they come
in from iran they come in from iraq
they're coming from saudi from lebanon
crazy and they're so passionate and
they're so
it's so beautiful to see like all the
flags out in the audience and and see a
kind of a unity for a couple hours in an
area that has so much turmoil the fact
that we can bring that music and help
inspire that unity is really really cool
isn't it wonderful to think that you
guys who were like you know living in
your living in your [ __ ] [ __ ] car
or something and like the thing has got
hamburger helper aren't you glad you
stuck with it how many times did you
almost quit the business honestly
not not many really
because you had no choice what the [ __ ]
would you have been doing what else are
we gonna do yeah we had no choice you
had nothing i mean you gotta break the
bones catching on fire you know but
people are screaming the f word in your
face someone said you gotta remember
though when you're when you're at that
time when we were living 30 years ago
when we could feed you know there was a
burger king next to where we lived and
for buck 99 we could go in and do five
guys on the salad bar because we would
sneak in and out of the back door
but they must have loved you a burger
king but at that time you don't know
anything different right you know what i
mean so it's like it's it's the unity
it's do you miss those days no
it's a lot more fun with money right
it wasn't matter it doesn't it doesn't
matter it wasn't better or worse money
lets us make a movie dude but dude did
you ever look at your friends who were
all starting to settle down and you see
and before you really even had any
success and things were going horribly
did you ever look at it and go oh my god
what where am i going to be in 15 years
when i have no no money and what if i
end up like one of these bands that
don't make it mm-hmm it didn't matter it
didn't matter whatsoever you were that
[ __ ] up going to burger king and
sharing the salad plate we thought we
were we were happening and look at look
at look
just look at the last three days of our
lives right on on saturday we're with
the apollo yesterday we were at yankee
stadium how was mariano and today we're
here with you i mean we're [ __ ]
living the dream still 32 years later
some people have said that metallica
almost broke up when um you guys saw my
ass cheeks at the uh when i was fart man
at the mtv that was a bad moment
a low point
shocking i have to say howard that was
quite a shock i am so ashamed that i did
that especially in front of you guys i
had no [ __ ] i was out of my [ __ ]
mind is what it was well it was we knew
you were gonna we've all had making
impairments but we didn't know you would
make that kind of you didn't was that
when you came in on the wire well i came
in you know i almost lost my fingers
that night because the wire was twisting
the reason that i feel bad about it
honestly i didn't understand the history
of the band and it was the first time
you guys were being honored at the mtv
awards and it really did mean something
to you because you know you guys really
had struggled and and there i am with my
ash cheeks while you're making a
heartfelt speech and i think lars you
put your foot up my [ __ ] i think i
had anal with you
uh you know what i mean were you guys
pissed afterwards or were you okay with
it
i was like what the [ __ ] was that
well you're a fan of monster movies
what's more hideous than my ass
let's be honest
talk about horror the movie the
metallica new 3d film and you really got
to see this thing metallica uh through
the never and if you're a fan and even
if you're not a fan of metallica you
will not believe the quality of this
film and the fact that you will feel
like you are in a rock band uh the way
they shot how many cameras are used in
something like this is there like 16 17
cameras or you have no concept it was a
lot
over 30 over 30 cameras i think wow i
mean and these are 3d cameras
yes yes we filmed a movie and brought
the crowd in and it was all about the
movie first and then making it the most
intense and uh uh
just uh you know the experience of you
being on stage like you were saying um
and then all of the footage with dane is
is high intensity yeah it's pretty cra
incredible and like when i was watching
you guys saying i was really genuinely
jealous like envious that i couldn't be
up on a stage in a band and i'm really
going to take some guitar lessons now
and i'm going to get started by the time
i'm 90 i should have my band in full
force you know what i mean it's never
too late man hey hey james why are you
the only guy with tattoos in the band
what do what is got some he does he
hides them though i was it was upsetting
me that there was more ink on stage uh
during uh the show you were upset i was
i was like you know i think the other
guy should get more in lars what about
you getting some ink you know what these
two guys make up for it i i don't need
tattoos
let's have a band tattoo come on come on
james are you sorry you're so heavily
tattooed do you like your tattoos
you know there's no regrets in my life
it all stuff happened for a reason and
you know i love art i love what's on
here sometimes uh i wonder what it would
be like if they weren't there but
they're there and the meanings change
behind them as life goes on too
as a dad are you gonna let your kids get
tattooed or did they ever come to how
old are your kids uh 11 13 15. so when
the 15 year old says i'm gonna go get
some tattoos do you say can you put your
foot down and say no that's not
acceptable yeah sure when you're 18 make
your own choices uh but until then we're
we're guardians of you and keeping you
safe you have your own path but uh when
did you get your first tattoo uh
37 maybe really really who's late or is
that something we're just telling the
kids
[Laughter]
do you oh do you you don't watch the mtv
awards do you guys you don't watch those
do you did you watch miley cyrus or any
of that tv still on it's still on
believe it or not they have awards and
time do you guys have awards do you pay
attention to the charts at all do you
pay attention to what's selling in pop
music
me personally no i'm not sure about the
other guys i definitely do not you do
not care why you sound like you're sick
and by it all are you
well you know it's just
uh the future is
in in music it's it's hard to find stuff
that that really gets me excited about
the future
don't you but also i mean two things
changed over the years number one
satellite radio and number two the ipod
so now when you're in your car all i
listen to is either satellite radio on
my ipod i don't really listen to
commercial radio anymore so you you sort
of stop paying attention you know yeah
you do our car
great ad for serious right there lars
yes
but every morning every morning it's a
it's a race between the kids on the
school grinder who can you know hijack
the ipod first or you know whatever
channel on on
on the satellite and it's it's just
commercial radios and non-entity i think
but don't you even say to yourself thank
god i'm not a band coming up now you
cannot sell albums now and you guys were
right about napster i do believe that i
always backed you on that i know you
took a lot of [ __ ] for it but a band
cannot make money with their music
anymore you can't sell albums am i
correct or not there's bands that are
they're they're trying they're doing
their best and they're not selling ways
it's getting creative there's there's
new ways and i think if we were a band
coming up now we do our best and that's
all you would do and uh these bands are
passionate about what they do but they
find a way but they can't break through
on a large scale like metallica do your
kids love music yes they do do you spank
them when they listen to some of this
[ __ ] do you teach them
something what is what are they getting
for
for listening to this [ __ ]
i think the next generation they have to
have their own music man they they got
to i you know i loved it when my parents
hated my music that's just a part of it
but that's what it is yeah we are
celebrating your movie today we are
celebrating metallica
what uh honor to have you guys in here
playing like this
it is just [ __ ] great the new 3d film
is so great it's uh through the never
you saw it right richard tell the fans
what you thought i was moshing in my
chair like going nuts and smacking
people next to me and just going crazy
it was awesome the sound i can't wait
there's an album coming out too right
like with the movie the sound was
perfect
like the production was and and it's so
loud in the theater too it was really
like you're in a concert it was awesome
also there's a metallica channel on
sirius which i think is fantastic
because i can pump iron to it do you
pumping iron all day
i'm telling you i'm going to get in some
shape you will
you know because it you know also you
know you in a band it doesn't matter how
you look too right you got to work out
right you got to physically take care of
yourself you guys play very hard i don't
think it's for the weak right well for
us we we stay in shape not so much to
look good but to sort of be able to do
it it's the physicality of what we do
that we have to be respectful too so i
think we're all in better shape now than
we've ever been because we eat well we
work out and and we sort of respect it
we have
uh jeff and a couple other guys that
massages and stretches and put us back
together afterwards has anyone become a
vegetarian
you did kirk i i last time i i ate red
meat was in 1985 because the right tour
james made fun of axel rose and said he
looks like a vegemitarianism
or something like that remember you did
that i eat only meat you only eat meat
raw meat
well this band is fantastic uh for more
information go to
throughthenevermovie.com i wish you a
lot of luck with it it's something
spectacular to be proud of thank you uh
and you boys are going to honor us with
one last song
let's talk about this song this song is
called enter sandman this is really
about
horrible
dreams yes nightmares as a kid
nightmares as a kid and who could blame
you for having nightmares as a kid and
nobody came when you had a nightmare did
they did anyone comfort you ever
yeah i got comfort yeah you got broken
lars did there he is what did you do to
cover them
let me sleep at his house let me come
over and he can uh record all his
records he can learn about music he
spent a lot of time at my house when we
started hanging out it was uh we just
hung out in my room for the first two
years or something and listen to music
and do you think that's why you wish
like lars almost i don't want to say he
stood in for your father or your family
but he became your family right that's
not such a weird thought when you think
about it
i mean you had you had a lot of brothers
and sisters though didn't you i two
older brothers and a younger sister and
a younger sister what are they doing now
are they in a band they're not in a band
the my my my brother dave who uh who was
in a band he got back together with his
buddies for his 60th birthday and he
invited me along to play with him it was
a huge moment it was very cool and you
know learning uh you know jimi hendrix
and some of the old 60s stuff that they
used to play it was a lot of fun did you
do an homage to jimi hendrix saturday
night at the apollo when you got down on
your knees and was that it was that the
no you played jimmy hendrick yeah kirk
played uh jimi hendrix yeah well i found
out that jimi hendrix won a talent show
or amateur talent show there in 1964
yeah oh is that why you played that yeah
yeah yeah
i played a little bit of voodoo child
because i was feeling i was feeling the
spirit of jimmy on that stage for sure
you have to tell the rest of the band
you're going to do that ahead of time
before you start doing that i don't know
if i mentioned it or not i just it just
comes up
while i was i was feeling it
and i thought james was doing an homage
when you got that on your knees i
thought you're going to let your [ __ ]
guitar on fire or something it almost
looked like a woodstock fire but that's
been done before was that an homage to
uh jimmy well no i fell down you just
fell down okay that's it i was tired so
this song is about nightmares when you
when you're a child nightmares occur
right and uh that's it i mean what more
needs to be said about this song right
right well i mean that uh i think the
whole thing of wanting to comfort your
child wanting to to keep them safe from
everything but when they go to sleep you
can't you can't keep them safe there's
stuff that enters their mind or that's
creating you know whatever subconscious
that you can't save them from so at that
point when you're a kid you have to
start standing up for yourself and
you've got to battle the world even in
your dreams how long to write this song
do you remember writing it it took a
while because i think the original
lyrics for this were were about
something else it was about family but
what was it about lars yeah
it was about a dysfunctional family
really so why is lars laughing at that
why because you didn't like the original
no that's putting it mildly saying
dysfunctional family
it was uh my recollection was about [ __ ]
death
crib
a song about crim death that's
dysfunctional
did you say to james hey i don't think
we should write a song about craig
douglas about crib death
did you say that what happened what
happened would the story be different
really
i'd like to hear the original thing not
be here because i would like to hear the
original lyric
[Laughter]
bob rock bob rock and i looked at each
other and went
maybe we should chat with james i go why
don't you chat with james
and he went and said hey james crib
death is kind of a little too out there
well
that's too dark it was not so much about
the commercial elements it was just more
it was like whether that was the the
fitting vibe for the music
the the music for enter sandman was the
first we did four records
and they got each more and more
progressive along the way and justice
for all was like this ultimate in
10-minute songs and songs that were all
over the place and so we sat down
afterwards and wanted to try to simplify
a little bit and enter sandman was the
first song that we wrote we wrote it
literally like in a day wow and um it
seemed like um the lyrics were not super
fitting to the simplicity of the music
do you remember the original title was
it enter sandman or was it something
else
um no i don't think it was titled i
don't think the song was ever titled
until right at the very end
um yeah a lot of the songs aren't titled
the end it's like it's like naming your
dog or you know or uh
you know it's like uh until you find out
the character of it then you can name it
it's like it's a nickname for the song
will you ever go back and write a song
about crib death do you think well now
you will bring back those lyrics please
debut that here if you will
not on the metallica channel don't lose
those lyrics we're celebrating the new
3d film metallica through the never here
is a song
that the boys leave you with originally
about crib death
and now clean up a little bit
take it away boys
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he goes
hey
never never lived
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
the double
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
in your head
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah yes
i could do that all day
watch you guys i mean
is that hard on your voice singing this
early in the morning hell yeah did you
do is there a period of time that your
voice has to recover because you you
sing hard yeah you do do you have to
wait a couple of days between concerts
it is good nowadays to wait uh you know
we don't do three in a rows anymore we
don't do five shows in one week because
why you tore up your voice well it would
it would not sound great and you know
it's not sounding great this morning but
i think you will you know thank you if i
miss you but all of us all of us need a
little more time to recover we're uh
we're getting up there in age and we're
not afraid of it we just need to care
for it you take vocal training no you do
not no there are times when i see a
vocal coach you know me and robert you
know robert has certainly stepped up man
yeah robert is doing more actually
he's over there doing stuff right yeah
you're doing it man one of the things
when i remember when i joined this band
i mean i learned so much it's like
collaborating with them on new music and
and just even like getting into the
backup vocal thing and i mean they've
made me a better musician when you first
joined the band didn't they [ __ ] with
you and like um like they didn't even
put bass on one of the albums
i don't know
right
right wasn't that true guys wrong guy is
it the wrong guy what is the other guy
be the bass player metallica's not so
lucky is it well
i feel i mean be careful now you know
they're embracing uh
the instrument um you know like they
haven't in many years but uh what what i
wanted to say this is an interesting
little site running for office yes back
in 1993
um i was touring in a band called
suicidal tendencies and we were opening
for metallica right and and there was a
and a tour party in madrid spain
and i was sitting with lars and james we
were drinking a bottle of jagermeister
little did i know i drank the whole
bottle of jaegermeister i thought that i
was drinking with them those were the
days uh james have another shot yeah so
i always say that was uh my christening
uh um back your initiation
do you guys wear earplugs when you play
do you wear something to protect your
hearing because i've never heard a
louder band in my life i mean it was
[ __ ] insane
do you wear something to protect your
ears we wear what's called in-ears these
little in-ear monitors you have to right
or else you'd go deaf oh yeah pete
townsend's practically deaf from the who
i mean he can't hear a thing and
probably in the beginning you guys
didn't wear any [ __ ] ears [ __ ] oh no
up where i was sitting um uh in front of
uh the monitor that had james's rhythm
guitar that was that measured like 125
db up there which is like the same level
as a jet engine yeah you guys are like
the loudest band i've ever heard in
front of that for like 10 years oh and i
was on tour in germany i remember this
clear
one night uh in the middle of the night
i went up and i was like oh my god
something's [ __ ] up so i woke up went
over to turn the tv off and it wasn't on
and then i realized wait a minute maybe
i should start dealing with so i started
wearing earplugs that was about 10 years
in have you suffered hearing loss any of
you guys oh yeah yeah yeah i had the
similar similar experience that lars has
with uh
tinnitus yeah the did you get the ring
the ringing you still get it
yeah wow yeah i i think the three of us
have have had that for like the last
20 years or so tinnitus yeah
[ __ ] tennis tonight tonight
can they get rid of it i mean you walk
around wait a second you guys walk
around and you hear a ringing in your
ears all the time along with all the
other voices yeah and it gets worse if
you're like fatigued or under stress or
any or something like that you know
it it thank god we're not underrated it
gets loud
lucky you have no stress in your life no
but seriously isn't that the most
annoying thing to walk around to hear
that right do you get used to it get
used to it i mean it's it it's sad but
you learn how to deal with it the
hardest thing for me is that you can
never hear what other people are saying
like if you're sitting in a restaurant
and there's like a little bit of music
in the background a lot of trendy
restaurants will have music you got to
like lean in you know huh what say that
again
like start actually i mean i'm not
making this up you got to sometimes like
sit and really like concentrate on
people's faces and their mouths and to
see what they're saying it helps to be a
little bit of a lip reader if you have
tonight but isn't that sad you guys are
such great musicians it could come to
the point where you can't hear your
music right i mean you'll be like
[ __ ] beethoven or whatever the whole
thing is writing yeah it was beethoven
it's not getting worse i think we've
sort of got it under um under control we
do a lot of uh you know we do some
public service announcements and stuff
with a company called here and try to
just sort of talk to people about you
know what can happen i mean when i was a
kid
i was you know 10 12 years old i
remember we used to sit and have
competitions with my friends we'd put
records on and we'd see who could have
headphones on and have it on 10 for the
longest period of time just nonsense
like that so you just sit and talk yeah
i talk to my kids a little bit and say
listen when you sit there and listen to
this [ __ ] so loud just know that 30
years from now you may not be able to
hear anything and then you've done
something as you could oh it's so crazy
you don't have ringing in your ears
howard i don't have ring in my ear but i
have a small [ __ ] if anyone wants to
hear about that
i mean if we're bringing up our problems
uh you're giving a public service
announcement
try going through like yeah i'm actually
recording one today tiny penis syndrome
it's a real drag you guys don't want to
hear about it
do you get tired of playing any certain
songs like billy joel retired just the
way you are or something one of the
songs he told me he retired because he
couldn't stand you know playing it
anymore are there any of your songs you
just cannot ever [ __ ] stomach playing
again
no no
and we play we play a lot of i mean the
thing that we do for we've been doing it
for about 10 years now is we play a
different set list every night we
haven't actually played the same set
list since 2003 yeah so uh 10 years so
we have about what 60 songs that we can
more or less more or less play yeah
and we're going to play master puppets
and we're going to play one but there's
about 60 songs that we rotate and all
the other except in china
right
and china uh master of puppets in china
yeah bill listen the chinese are being
led like puppets is that your point
maybe that was probably the government's
point
the government said you cannot play that
yeah we had to give them a uh
oh yeah a whole set of songs and they
went through all the lyrics and okay
which ones we can play which ones we
couldn't play aren't you shocked by a
government that has to be so anal
about music about music it's [ __ ]
they're so scared over there about their
people getting on the internet or
anything like that it is a bummer and
like you know
they see they see a a lyric like master
of puppets being so subversive that you
know
they're not allowing us to play it it's
kind of scary you shouldn't just [ __ ]
pay attention to it of course which that
doesn't work did you consider cancelling
the show tell you something there were
40 000 kids over those two nights that
were i mean [ __ ] they were really
responding to what we're doing it was
the chinese oh it was insane whatever
rules they set down
they they didn't i mean the fans were
there to have fun we got our foot in the
door we were able to go and play in
china that was the key how do you think
your music even gets into china when you
think about it right like bootlegs who
likes it yeah yeah isn't that crazy
that's great it's great did you consider
cancelling borders man when the
government but when the government said
to you you cannot play master of puppets
did you consider canceling no no no no
you know what i did is i during i had
like a or a
open guitar solo thing where i just sit
there and riff i played the riff for
master puppets and a couple other songs
that weren't allowed to be played but i
played this just the music so i kind of
snuck into your own way of being
subversive exactly i like that and the
audience knows what's happening right
totally i mean it's not a secret i mean
what we're talking about here is not a
secret they published it on government
websites what songs we could play and
what we couldn't i mean it's it's fine
how'd you choose the set list for the
movie like that's a tough like you know
the movie is going to sort of be there
forever
we asked the chinese government chinese
government wrote the setlist
[ __ ] know what they were doing their
shows went over big yeah i like that the
chinese government had to listen to your
music and make a set list that's so
beautiful whose job was that that is
great
yeah yeah boys what can i say
a million thanks i know getting up early
and doing this you certainly don't need
this aggravation but you have given me
the treat of a lifetime to sit this
close and watch you guys play is just
remarkable and you guys are masterful
musicians and i would give you the
kennedy center honor but those [ __ ]
won't listen to me
they haven't given you one if we get
there maybe you could uh give us the
award or induct us on your ass with my
ass cheeks flying against my small [ __ ]
bring the wire back you guys will be
accepted to the kennedy center honors
way before i will man it ain't gonna
happen in my lifetime well we thank you
howard man for having us and supporting
us and you've always been in support for
us well you bet i love this band this
band may you long live and may you
prosper and thank you for the metallica
channel thanks for the new movie too 3d
film metallica through the never and
anytime you guys feel like playing you
know where to come
thank you thank you brother all right
i'll never see you again i'm sure but
whatever
[Laughter]
and uh we'll be back after these words
you